the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life i'm ken coleman and i'm
joined by my colleague anthony o'neil
we are ramsey personalities and we host
shows on
the ramsey network as well but we are
with
you and for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five is
their number to jump in
and uh we are going to talk about money
which of course you come to know and
expect that here on the ramsey show
uh we'll talk about uh your
relationships
young people and and we'll talk about
your work
working on purpose both anthony and i
have made steps and as part of our
journey here in ramsey solutions
stepping out
in faith on purpose to do what we
were born to do it so we'll help you on
anything that you need
we always have a great time together how
are you sir hey man i'm doing well
you ready to roll hey let's do it all
right triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh let's go to armin
uh who joins us
in los angeles how can we help
hey guys how are you doing oh we're
living the dream what's going on
uh so before i ask my question i just
wanted to give some context so
i'm currently 17 years old and i want to
pursue a career of becoming a cultic
lawyer
i'm about to finish my last semester at
a community college and i have saved up
about seven thousand dollars
and so the university that i'm
transferring to is gcla
and although it's great and all i am
however faced with a pretty big dilemma
and so i live 30 miles away from ucla so
i'm concentrating on if i should buy
a car with the money i have saved up or
if i should choose to live there in a
dorm or an apartment
which will be a big financial investment
and so
the the benefit of what i'm thinking of
commuting is i'll be able to keep my my
part-time job
at a law firm and the good thing about
that is because i want to become a
corporate lawyer
the experience that i gained from there
is crucial
and so i've also spoken with various
attorneys at my workplace who have gone
to ucla
and counselors and professors and
they've all said the same thing and keep
in mind i've spoke to these people who
have also been to ucla
and all these people have said that oh
well it's a one time
one once in a lifetime uh experience
and uh essentially i have to i have to
live there to
get that experience and that it's a very
crucial part of
of my development as a human being
because you get to socialize with these
intellectual colleagues so i'm
just torn yeah let me ask you this and
my colleagues ready to go he's
he's ready um how much
ex more expensive will it be you've told
us it's a good bit more expensive i want
to know how much and then
do you even have the ability to do that
despite all these wonderful lawyers
telling you it's a wonderful thing to do
so they're saying well um obviously i'm
gonna have to incorporate some student
loan
debt with that and now ucla has given me
a grant of
15 000 which covers my tuition but
the the the side effect of that is
uh it's another 15 000 which they've
given
me um yeah so you can't afford it you
can't afford it
basically yeah yeah yeah ayo yeah man
you know i'm on
i want to be respectful because you
sound like a very young bright
man and it sounds like you're confused
because you are being misled
uh by people around you oh my gosh this
is an experience well i want you to
really think about this
your experience is going to cost you
about 45 to 50
000 in debt and then you're gonna have
another
journey of an experience for 20 years
after that to pay it off
what kind of experience is that crap
okay and so for me you know now hold on
hold on bro
i got you i i wanna i wanna help you
and i want to go to ucla i'm from
oceanside california
so i hear you on ucla i think it's a
great opportunity
i want to be honest with you uh but the
experience of racking up debt is an
experience that you're not going to be a
part of i have no problem
saying that um now talk to me about this
seven thousand dollars in the commute
um so this yeah so the seven thousand
dollars into mute i
uh from from my part-time job at the
last one i incorporated
about seven thousand dollars oh so are
you living at home right now
yeah with my parents what kind of car do
you have right now
i i don't have a car okay all right cool
so let me get this straight
if you spend seven thousand dollars and
go buy a quality car
you can stay at home keep your part-time
job that generates
income for you that also could possibly
set you up for a full-time job later on
once you graduate
and pass the bar exam and stuff like
that with the law firm you're building
relationships
and you can go to school debt-free
because you're getting your tuition
covered from the fifteen thousand
dollars
is that story correct yes or no yes
that's correct then young man that's an
experience that you need to be going for
because not only are you getting a
paycheck young man you're getting a
paycheck
but then ken talks about this in his
book the proximity principle
you are already in proximity of lawyers
and you never know what they can do to
help you through
that's a that can that's what i want i'd
rather be around
the proximity of my future than the
proximity of debt
what the heck let me just add to that uh
let me give you a different experience
that uh you may not have a vision for
all these lawyers
see they're not thinking about your
financial future they're just telling
you about all of their memories and they
did it the way everybody else does it
but
uh armin listen to me when you stay with
your mom and dad
and you get that seven thousand dollar
car or whatever you're gonna buy five
thousand whatever and you keep going you
don't accrue debt
and you get out of ucla and you're now
working for that law firm or another law
firm because you're way ahead of the
game as anthony said guess what
you can have all kinds of experiences
when you travel around the globe with
that fat
lawyer salary that has no debt you're
sipping from coconuts
anywhere you want to go brother so i got
to tell you something
ucla is pretty cool i've seen the campus
ao
that's your neck of the woods it's a
gorgeous experience but i got to tell
you something
it's not that great it's not as great as
the vacations you're going to be able to
take
the house you're going to be able to
afford because you have no debt
and because you're a rocking lawyer so
ao
and if he was on my show uh what would
you what would you do i would add this
in there you know james may you know
fire me on the next segment
please don't do that but i really want
to do the show with you i do too okay
but when you're young
when you're debt-free yeah when you're a
lawyer making that kind of money you
talking about sipping coconut you
sipping coconuts
with a beautiful beautiful beautiful
woman next time i should have known you
single guys
right right yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of great experiences
in his future yes there uh if he decides
to stay at home
yeah and drive that car paid for a car
by the way oh
brother uh that's a different caliber of
women right there
okay i don't know what to do with that
but uh
the advice still is the same and uh you
know
here's the thing here's what the uh the
learning
um here's what the lesson is from this
call
there are some well-meaning people who
are very successful
who will give young people bad advice
yeah absolutely hey it's a great
experience
go go take out a loan you got to live on
campus man you got to be a part of the
party scene at ucla
trust me you're never going to forget
that and these are well-meaning people
but it's just
awful advice awful awful awful advice
ah well that's why we're here ayo yes
sir all right listen
ao's warmed up as you can tell we're
ready to go
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five dial it right now
we're here for you don't move more of
the ramsey show right around the corner
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70
a month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter
[Music]
wireless
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions
world headquarters i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague anthony o'neil as
we take your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you got your money questions ao's
ready to go
how about questions about that bigger
shovel making
more money making more impact income and
impact
that's what i focus on on the ken
coleman show as a part of the ramsey
network my colleague anthony o'neil uh
new podcast
the table with anthony o'neil it's been
a big hit on youtube now he's bringing
it to you
in podcast form as well so search the
table
with anthony o'neil on youtube as well
as anywhere podcasts are available
you can check out the ken coleman show
again youtube as well anywhere podcasts
are available
siriusxm and your local talk radio
station so
let's get to it triple eight eight two
five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to sacramento california
where jack
joins us jack how can we help
hey guys how you guys doing we're living
the dream what are you doing
well i'm doing all right so i'm gonna
first first off i just wanted to say
thank you guys so much for the work you
guys do at least
i listen to you every day i love it so
thank you for the work you do thank you
sir
so i'm going to give a little context
before i ask my question
so my wife and i make about 81 000
total uh household income but she
actually got a promotion and she's going
to
go up to we're gonna go up to about
ninety six thousand dollars
uh connects months uh however
i work in the nonprofit world and i've
been in the nonprofit world
ever since i graduated college about
seven years ago
and i would like to continue to keep
working in the
health and human services field however
i'm looking for a new job and one of the
things i'm struggling with
is that i would like to increase my
income and increase my shovel
but i need a little help knowing how to
do that i've been looking for jobs
and a lot of it is needs
some sort of like master's degree or
they get paid about the same amount as i
do i'm looking to stay
in the area that i'm at and so i just
kind of need some guidance on that
okay well so we wouldn't want to pursue
any kind of higher education like a
master's
if it's going to pay you the same amount
of money and and so if you're it depends
on what you're looking to
advance to so in this health and human
services
non-profit world am i hearing that
that's the combination
yeah and so i've worked in a variety of
settings with
kids in foster care health insurance now
okay so i do a variety of things but i
wanna i want to primarily work
with youth or helping kids uh mentor
kids with like those kinds of things
that's that's what i'm really passionate
about
okay um so they're looking at them so
let's focus on that
that's where we look first see we we
don't
we must focus on the work that we want
to do and then we figure out the income
situation
it it doesn't flip okay because i can
tell you i get calls every day ao on the
ken coleman show where people just took
a promotion six months ago a year ago
they took it from money and they're
miserable
and again there's all kinds of data out
there you know
two-thirds of people would rather take a
pay cut to do meaningful work
are you kidding me so this is real so
jack because you
very very clear you want to help young
people underserved young people
you know those people and you know that
you know the people you want to serve
and you know where they are
you know who's serving them true or
false that's true
a lot of the places sometimes pay less
than i do so i'm looking at jobs like at
the state level okay
so now you've done the work you've
really answered your own question you
must first focus on who is it that you
want to serve
and you know who they are and you know
who's serving them and so you are going
to be
somewhat limited is to your options
based on the finances now you said you
guys are going to be combined 96 000
what's your cut of that once your wife
gets that promotion what's your cut
so i make about 50 000 okay so if you're
looking at working for the state
and serving young people that are uh you
know underserved or whatever that
situation looks like whether that's in
the foster care
uh or in maybe welfare type programs
whatever that is you know what that is
are there positions if you get in and
then eventually move up that will allow
you to make 50 or more
yes there have been some i i had like i
said i've looked at the state level but
i
also wouldn't mind staying at the
non-profit level i think
the problem i run into is sometimes the
culture
hasn't been great or there's been good
pay but not good culture
or vice versa right so here's the deal
this is called
i gotta go out and i gotta look i gotta
examine i gotta talk to people
and we don't judge any future
opportunities on what we faced in the
past you know ao
you know you can't get discouraged when
you go okay i found something
uh that looks pretty good but well you
know
the income's good culture's not good
well i just don't think i'm going to
find it
and the question here that jax asked is
how do i do it i wish i had some super
deep answer but it doesn't exist
the simple way of how is i keep turning
over rocks here's the example i use
yeah uh i have been walking along with
my wife at times
and uh the women out there in the lobby
will know what i'm talking about so will
the dudes
and all of a sudden the back of her
earring falls off or something and the
earring just falls down you know it's
kind of like what's going on
and when it falls down what do we do you
know we just immediately look down and
we go where'd it go and we
we know it fell down and we stop we
pause we go i'm in this area
i know it fell in this area it has to be
in this area true or false it has to be
there
so what do we do i know you don't know
this because you don't do many moonlight
walks on the beach uh but anyway
the point is is that this is the same
thing jack knows
the area he wants to be in true true so
the opportunities
he knows the area so the opportunities
they're there in this area so what do i
do
just like we're looking for that back of
earring or whatever uh
turning over rocks if we're in a rocky
path or we're on out there we're just
looking we're just
turning over we're looking at everything
examining i mean we're down is on our
hands and knees
looking for the back of that earring and
i think that's
that's the thing here this is intensity
this is
absolute intensity and intentionality
to look for what i'm looking for and
here's the reality
you're going to be limited at times but
if you're limited to 50 000 you're
limited to 50 000 here's what we know
about teachers
uh the median salary across this nation
for teachers is about 60 000 it's the
median
but we also know from our largest
millionaire study ever that ramsay
solutions did
that the third largest group of everyday
millionaires net worth millionaires were
teachers
so don't tell me you can't make enough
money the income you need
and the impact you want four four excuse
me that's wrong number that's my number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five you ever done that say
the wrong phone number
nah because that's what happens i don't
have a phone number you don't have a
phone number on the table no can i get
one
because you're guest only you don't so
you don't take millennials even use the
phone anymore
so dave dave uses the phone we use the
phone on the kid called
we text john deloney does yeah i said
besides texting oh besides texting
yes john's only he's not a millennial
yeah that's true we
john and i are in our fourth all right
but you know a serious question um i
hear that often like
on within the millennials you know man
well the pay is good but the culture is
lack or the culture is so good but the
pay is wack so and and they always say
i'm looking for good pay good culture
good people yeah
and and your expertise because i'm not
the expert in this field
can you find all three of those sharique
so do you advise people to only go to
where you find all three of those
well i try to tell you to try to get
there now there may be a season where
if you're on your career ladder and you
go all right here's the deal
this is this is giving me the pay and
the experience that i need
it's not a great culture but if i know
i'm not there long term i can bite my
lip i can be a big boy put on my big boy
pants okay
and i can put up with it you know as
long as it's not an abusive situation
okay
but we talk about this all the time you
can be in the right role i'm glad you
bring this up
you can be in the right role what you
were designed to do i call it the sweet
spot where you use your talent
to perform your passion to accomplish
your mission okay
but in an awful culture you could be in
your dream job and after about six weeks
walk into that awful culture you can go
oh i can't do this anymore so that's
doing the right thing in the wrong place
and what you want to do is you want to
be in the right role
in the right place in other words the
right seat on the right bus
okay and that's what you got to go from
by the way that is possible
now i'm glad you brought this up ao
because
you you've been in the church world
you've worked for some big time churches
absolutely where there are great
positions but maybe the culture
you know whatever the situation is but
here's the deal it may take a little
longer to find that
but it is always worth it yes absolutely
always worth it
uh hey we just mentioned the table so uh
tell people why they need to listen to
the show
i mean we had to break we are having an
intentional conversation about how to
get out of debt how to build wealth how
to have how to house
how to have successful relationships so
come on over there i challenged will
smith
recently you did oh yeah on the workout
challenge i just posted on my ig go
check it out his dad bod thing you went
after him i went after him i really hope
he responds i hope that would make my
life to see you and he uh working out
together oh it's gonna go good all right
we'll see what happens hey let me tell
you what else is going to happen
we're coming right back don't move this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education the army
national guard the army national guard
believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague anthony o'neal
and we are here taking your questions
triple eight eight two five
five two two five questions about money
questions about
your work hey do you want to enjoy going
to work you want to make
more income uh hey you got some
you got some uh relationship and single
questions oh ao's here he's the
he's our designated uh you know you know
you didn't set out to be this but
because you are the only ramsey
personality right now that happens to be
single
uh i know you love when i share that
information out there i mean you know
that you kind of got the edge on that
you talk about it on the table i mean
listen i mean
there's something wrong being said no
who said there was right so i i got to
take all those questions to you
oh thank you so any of those questions
hey i'm in a relationship
uh we're not married uh we're not seeing
eye to eye ao is
on duty hey man listen and i sit here
and i watch and i go
i'm the old married guy and i just let
him roll yeah man so we'll take those
questions too
absolutely you take the merry questions
and i'll take the single question
and i'm not the relationship expert but
i can give you some advice
well from things i've learned during my
yes you can you can take
money and relationships on from that
unique perspective yes
i've been married so long i just say yes
dear do you know what i mean
we just hit 23 years i would never
become a yes man
oh he says that and all the married
dudes out in the lobby like okay we'll
see how that
we'll see how that look at this guy in
the front row right there in the front
row man
he was like i don't know man look at it
right there look at right there there we
go look at the man the red shirt by the
way congratulations just finished his ph
he did man i love that that's an
educated brother that oh that's a yes
man
i love that hey uh you need to find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best
deal today's question ao comes from
calista in nebraska she
says i'm a dental hygienist but i'm
considering getting a bachelor's degree
in something that would be more
fulfilling
and give me more opportunities i'd love
to be a teacher
but the pay is not the best i've also
considered nursing school
because of the potential income but i
wonder
if i would end up feeling unfulfilled
again
do i choose my career based on finances
or adjust my finances for the career the
answer is and always will be if you ask
me
be you must always choose
what you were created to do and you
adjust your lifestyle
to that i mentioned this earlier
teachers
who across the nation the median income
is 60 000 they are the third largest
group of everyday millionaires which
means they live
on less than they make they are very
fulfilled in other words
they've got plenty of income because
they're working for impact and i say
this on the ken coleman show
every day when i start the show you were
created to contribute
you were created to work you don't work
to live you live to work and that
doesn't mean becoming a workaholic and
putting all your value in your paycheck
what it means is
you were created to contribute that's
why everybody that i talked to on the
show ao who calls in and they're very
confused can i don't know what i want to
do with my life i just want to help
people everybody says that because we
all long to make a difference so
the answer is figure out what you're
supposed to do you can call my show
we'll do a deep dive with you
uh once you figure it out you adjust
your lifestyle to that you know what ken
i want to add something to that
all right not really necessary to the
question but to the point you just made
and i really want america to hear this
out how is it that
teachers who are making on average
median income
uh making sixty thousand dollars a year
right uh but then they are retiring
millionaires yeah i i i i want to teach
right here
from the money principle do it you say
live below your means that's how they're
doing it they're living below their
means they're paying off their debt
and then also in that same study that we
did we found out that they're also
paying off their mortgage yes
watch this uh when they retire if they
have
one million dollars in their retirement
funds
and then they just let's say they just
draw the interest only don't pull from
the one million
let's just say the interest is ten
percent at that time it's a hundred
thousand dollars
so i know america are probably probably
saying where are you gonna get ten
percent from
that added up well i can talk to that
too but let's just go down to the low
end let's say it's eight percent that's
eighty thousand dollars
so when she retires she's debt-free has
a million dollars in her account and she
gets a 20 000
pay raise yeah that's right to go retire
why because over a period of time she
didn't chase
money she chased happiness and while she
was chasing her happiness
her fulfillment like you taught uh she's
living the money principles that
that we teach live below your means you
know have the nice things
pay off your debt stay away from debt
and so when she retires not only she has
seven figures that she could pass down
to her kids and to her kids kids but she
gets a twenty thousand dollar
when she stops working and she can now
go enjoy life i just had to add that in
there it's great for all y'all people
saying oh you gotta make a million
dollars a year no you don't no
and not only did he make the financial
case let me make the soul case
not only has she had a raise in
retirement
she's going to get to the end of her
journey look back and reminisce
not regret so good and that's what this
journey is all about
i love it triple eight eight two five
five two two five sameer joins us in st
louis missouri samir how can we help
yes it's a pleasure to talk to you
gentlemen uh so so quickly i started
i found red uh dave about four years ago
and i paid off like 250 thousand dollars
in debt uh
way to go that's serious stuff
yes sir i'm debt free i just paid off my
house i paid off 104 000 on the 12th
wow and i am looking to buy another
house but
i need to do something called a bridge
loan
which is i think some kind of temporary
loan because i don't have
uh 20 to put down on a new house so i
have to wait
to sell my house or you know
in order to put their money down now
towards the new house
get this no no because aka it's also
called a caveat loan all right
and so those typically go from like two
weeks to about three years and what i
want you to do is
um i want you to go ahead and sell your
current loan i mean not your loan
sell your current house uh you are
already debt free you have already made
the right moves
i do not want you to go back because
here's the thing
if you get this loan let's say life
happens within the next year
now you're stuck with that and you do
not and you will not qualify
for the next loan so what i want you to
do man is just be patient
sell this house in this market you can
sell that house fast
um and then take that income from the
home and go on over
and purchase your new home i had to do
that ken had to do that
um so i mean trust me this would be a
temporary loan what does your house
worth
uh i'm thinking it will sell for like uh
2 30. i've lived in it uh 11 years now
and i paid 130 whenever i bought it
yeah you're in st louis the market's
white hot pretty much
everywhere and so you sell that for 230
like ao said what's the new house going
to cost you
uh 4 10. so 20 percent you got more that
you got plenty
plenty you basically got half yeah 50
down you don't even have to do that per
se but i mean why are you in an
itch to uh not wait on the home can you
not do a contingency
where you put an offer down on building
or whatever
and it's based on the contingency of you
selling your home
no because there's no there's no houses
in the area where i'm looking at
uh and nobody wants to wait i try doing
that and they don't they're not really
okay wait
i got you that's fine but ao is still
right i mean you just you're just gonna
have to be patient and that's hard i get
it yeah
i agree yeah be patient yeah you got
this you know i mean
this is such a crazy real estate market
that it's got people kind of going hey i
mean
but here's here's the point you know
houses are still going to be there
absolutely excellent you know at some
point he has done such a tremendous job
he's in an enviable position yeah and if
they're not there
he can wait and go build one right he's
going to have a hundred thousand dollars
in equity
sounds like he makes good money i mean
here's the thing patience
is worth it in the long run you do not
want to make a
hasty decision based upon emotions uh
just sit still be tight and you'll be
all right
yeah yeah i absolutely agree on that all
right ao question from
desean on facebook i'm in i'm a
sophomore in college i'm currently debt
free my college is paid for my
scholarships i've got 1500
in savings i'm 21. how can i make sure
not to get in debt
how do i maximize my money from my job i
mean if you're graduating debt-free i'll
go ahead and just part that money into a
savings account get the thing up to
three months at her age level
uh and then that's how you stay out of
debt i mean if you get a fully funded
emergency fund if an emergency happens
you don't have to go back into debt to
cover that emergency
but i want to give her some some cool
points here brother before we go to
break
do you know that nearly 52 percent of
people in america don't even have a
thousand dollars in their savings yeah
she's already about 21 year old no debt
scholarship gonna be in great shape
great advice ao all right don't move he
is anthony o'neil i'm ken coleman
this is the ramsay show we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by anthony o'neal and
we're taking your questions about your
life
how about those money questions getting
out of debt
savings investing what do you got hey
how about work
oh man i'm in a dead-end job or my job's
okay but i want to
i want to move into something else i
want to get promoted i actually want i
like the work i just want to get
promoted
i'm moving into a leadership position
hey how do i do that any of those work
questions career and and working on
purpose questions
well that's what i will work with you on
as well anthony o'neil taking your
calls with me ken coleman and we are
ramsey personalities check out our shows
on the ramsey network the table with
anthony o'neil
available on youtube and as a podcast
and the ken coleman show
on youtube podcast talk radio and
siriusxm
all right to the phones we go carbondale
illinois is where austin joins us austin
how can we help
hi gentlemen thanks for speaking with me
sure
i'm a relatively new supervisor less
than a year
in for a federal agency and i have a
small
group of employees that work for me
about four of them
and they are absolutely awesome and
being
uh within the federal agency i have
limited control over what kind of
financial
incentives i can offer them and i was
wondering if you had any advice
or recommendations on ways that i can
show my appreciation show my gratitude
that without it becoming
you know just the repetitive good job
nice work yeah okay
well you know um recognition and rewards
okay recognition and rewards and i know
you say y'all want to do a little bit
more than just
good job but recognition is something
you do in front of everybody you got a
small team
and i would combine those two words and
you can do this out of pocket even if
you're limited uh with the federal
agency not giving you a budget for this
because this isn't about
money but you could do something fun
like uh the person's favorite dessert or
their favorite
uh restaurant you get a gift card call
the whole group together there's only
four of them
and go hey sue sally john
jerry whoever it is they've been doing a
great job and i wanted to publicly
recognize them see that's the
recognition piece and you brag about
them publicly then you give them some
type of a reward
and again both the recognition and the
reward
it's not about how fancy it is or how
shiny it is or how expensive it is
it's just the fact that you're doing it
and you're showing them some love so it
could be that
simple uh and that's something that you
can do whether you have a budget for it
or not
makes sense thank you yeah absolutely
appreciate the call uh you know we know
this by the way
hr data folks shows that people would
rather be
publicly recognized and received some
type of reward which is the attaboy out
of girl and then hey good job i'm going
to give you an extra day off
you know or hey if i'm going to reward
and recognize
my colleague ao okay let's say i was
leading ao
all right here's what i know okay he
likes to find experiences
so i may pick his favorite restaurant i
may pick his favorite dessert i may
uh hook him up with a gift card or buy a
round of golf for him at a really sweet
golf course i may buy him a golf club
i may buy him some golf shoes all of
those things are personal to you
but it's really about recognizing you
it's not even the gift which is the
reward yeah i would love to join a king
coleman team
you need me to do that i can just do
that because you know i can just do that
listen man all right
round of golf i'd do it for one so again
we know that
from hr studies that people would rather
receive those things
than a raise yeah so let's not overthink
this leaders
just publicly recognize them and put a
little reward with it and it goes a
really long way
let's go now to chattanooga tennessee
where mary joins us mary how can we help
well i'm just kind of on what you were
talking about there trying to find ways
to encourage myself and others on this
journey because it's kind of
a budget type right now yeah tell me
where
what are you chat what are you
challenged by what are you trying to do
well i've been pulling my credit report
i got so far have
discovered over about 24 000 in debt
okay and i think you send my reads
through that and look at that and try to
pull that out and try to
deal with these creditors it's been
really really hard
yeah okay cool talk to us i mean
what what's what's what's so difficult
about it 24 000 in debt okay cool
i hear you uh what are you making it a
month i mean not a month
what's your annual income about nine
thousand
say it again about nine grand you make
nine thousand dollars a year
yeah i'm on a fixed income disability oh
okay so now that's why it's it's
discouraging
because i mean you don't have any income
so i'm gonna let the career expert help
you out
yeah because we gotta get we got to get
our shovel up yeah i mean i can give you
all the motivational tools
uh but it's still going to be
discouraging if we don't have an income
yeah mary uh break down your fixed
income situation obviously i understand
you're on a disability
and but what what would it take i mean
what are where are you limited
as much as you're comfortable sharing i
need to understand the disability and
then
then we deal with that fixed income um
i get less than a thousand a month most
of it goes to rent
more than half no i understand but what
is your disability what's what's
limiting you
um there's some backing issues okay and
and where are you are you seeing
somebody is there is there a light at
the end of the tunnel what's the
prognosis on the back
right well that's the time i'm learning
issues i have no insurance and no other
source of income on i'm getting bills
from
from predators countries use for medical
bills that i can't afford and i realize
i'm responsible for them
which apply as a new realization for me
okay but it's all new to me but
how to deal with that i'm getting a lot
of shut offs and shutdowns with the
collection issues and how to even
address any of this or how to proceed
with any of those
okay so you're not giving me some
overwhelming i get it okay so you're
you're not even getting treatment on the
back so the next question is what work
could you do today
even if it hurt what could you do
i don't know that's not true that's not
true i've heard that so many times mary
come on now come on mary
mary well i enjoy clerical work i enjoy
helping people i joined doing research
um it's just a matter of having the
tools that i would need to do that it's
then causes
cost money when you say clerical work
what do you mean you mean like
administrative assistant type work where
you're doing
uh lots of administrative tasks is that
what you mean
basically yeah kind of uh yeah i guess
that would be the case yeah something
that would be um kind of a hands-on
thing i would be doing have you done
that before for anybody
i've done a few times with volunteering
for nonprofits
yeah no let me marry so here's here's
the thing so ao i want you
to take over in just a second on what we
can do for her you know as far as the
coaching or we can get her some
counseling
the financial stuff but mary i'm going
to tell you something
ao's right 24 000
while it seems like a massive mountain
for you to climb i'm telling you it's
not
it is on a fixed income yes and you're
just you're not
even you're just you're just you're
trying not to drown
every month but i'm going to tell you
something mary it doesn't sound like to
me and i'm not in
any way minimizing your pain but it does
not sound like to me
like you are in so much pain that you
can't go work
and i'm telling you the way out of this
the financial pain and the physical pain
is work and let me tell you something
the economy in tennessee is really good
chattanooga is a thriving
economic center you need to go get
a job and if you're doing uh
basic administrative work or you're
working in a
a warehouse answering phones and put you
can be doing
way more than 9 000 a year you that
fixed income is holding you back
you need to drop the fixed income you
need to go hey i'm in pain
but i'm going to work and when i go to
work i'm going to go get a
job where i can get some benefits i'm
going to move into that
and then i'll start taking care of
myself physically you can get on the
phone with the creditors and go here's
my situation
i'll get to you when i get to you but 24
000 is doable and i want you to hang on
the line madison let's get her
um let's get her plugged into ramsey
plus let's also maybe if we can get uh
on her on the phone with one of our
counselors and coaches for a session to
kind of show her
step by step what she needs to do and
one of the and here's the thing
um um samantha you're going to get
counseling inside of ramsay plus so
please stand online let madison take
care of that
but i want to encourage you because what
i what i heard was excuses i didn't hear
um um i didn't hear anything that says i
cannot work so i want to be
sensitive to your pain i want to be
sensitive to your situation
but here's the truth in a respectful way
that the greatest enemy to your success
is your
excuse if you want to change things
around then you have to change your
mindset
that's the very first thing so i agree
with ken you got to get out there and
get a job you got to get out there and
look online and see what you can do
maybe from home
you can do something while you're also
getting your back looked at and situated
so stay on the line we'll get you
situated
and again respectfully we're praying for
you and your pain yeah
you know tough stuff but there is hope
and that is very surmountable you can
get over that all right
hey i want to thank our producer james
shiles and sitting in for kelly daniels
today madison browder
ao thank you my friend always a joy to
be with you but we want to thank you
america
thank you for listening this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show and it's where
america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life your money
your work your relationships and beyond
i'm ken
coleman and i'm joined by my colleague
anthony o'neil where ramsay
personalities both have shows as a part
of the ramsey network and we are here
for you
this hour triple eight eight two five
five
two two five is the phone number triple
eight eight
two five five two two five let's go
to boston massachusetts to get us
started this hour samantha
is there samantha how can we help hi
thanks very much for taking my call so i
am a professional pastry chef
and i work outside of the home in my
industry
and that's all fine and good um on the
side
i sometimes make custom cakes for people
mostly people who
come to me and ask me to do something
i'm not really big on promoting and
trying to sell myself because
i'm busy enough with my actual job job
um
but friends friends of friends
acquaintances people who've been at
parties that have had my
cakes sometimes come to me and want
cakes and things like that
and we're talking like the kind of cakes
you would see on television like a
custom sculpted car
yeah things that the going rate is like
350
like that's the legit rate that i can
that's what the market will bear that's
what i
you know can reasonably charge and they
take me a really long time so that's
what i do charge
and that's no problem when it's a
fairly affluent client i don't really
have too much i personally wouldn't pay
that much for a cake ever
but that's what i do so that's what i
charge
um sometimes though it's a friend or a
friend of a friend who i know
is broke and i know cannot afford that
and it's definitely
a want not a need it's beyond their
means they're not someone who's in a
position
that they should be spending 300 on a
cake but
it happens often enough that i just
don't know what to do when
when someone comes to me and they show
me something really elaborate and it's
got to feed 50 people and
they're excited because they know
someone who can do you know has a skill
set and can do something in their circle
so they want to
give me work and they want to show off
like hey i can you know i know someone
who can do this and look what i brought
to the party it's amazing
but i feel sick to my stomach when i
know i've been to their house i've spent
time with them socially and know how
they live
and i know this is not something that
they can reasonably
afford to spend on a cake and so i end
up
either under quoting dramatically or
you know trying to get out of doing it
and i'm i'm just at a loss of how to
handle
that because it seems to be happening
more and more and
like i said if this was just strictly i
was running a business and i needed to
just [ __ ] up and say
okay this is this is i have to charge
and this is what i have to do i have to
find a way to price reasonably
i think i'd be okay with it but it's
just you know it's this weird gray area
where they're like they're sort of
friends but more importantly than that
even the friends i can charge
what my time is worth but it's the it's
the fact that i
personally know them and i know that
this is not something that they
should be spending that much money on
based on their situation in life right
yeah i do i have a couple quick thoughts
first of all you are absolutely
a sweetheart uh of a person i mean
you're you're i mean your your heart is
all it's just kind of just kind of
overflowing out of the phone and i think
that you have to relax
so i think there's two responses um
you don't feel good when you make a cake
for less than 350 dollars you've made
that very clear it doesn't feel good to
you because it takes a lot of time
you already got a full-time job so
so i wouldn't make the cake unless you
feel good about making the cake and you
don't feel good about making the cake
if it's less than 350 so what you're
doing is because you
you are smart with your money and you
probably listened to the ram show for a
long time and you and you know too much
and you're going they can't afford that
and you're
you're placing their reality
on your shoulders and i don't think
that's your burden to bear
so you can say pass in those situations
where you know somebody can't afford it
or in your words
it's not a good use of their money but
you're not their financial counselor
you're somebody who makes a really nice
cake they want a really nice cake
and you know i've had i've been on the
show with dave before samantha where
someone will call in they work for a
bank
and they're trying to get out of debt
and they're like dave i i work for a
bank that gives out loans and he's like
no you're not a criminal you're not
doing anything unethical it's your job i
get it that it's a disconnect in values
but it doesn't make you a bad person for
making a cake for somebody
who may not be spending their money
wisely but in that situation samantha
instead of letting it eat you alive
just say i can't do that right now
sorry i'd like to i can't do it that's
one option okay
okay um and and then and then you need
to also get back to the point where you
go i'm only going to make cakes
for this it is what it is so so
you can't do a financial dossier on
everybody who buys a cake for me it's
going to drive you crazy
right so if you know too much
and it's not too much but i know what
you're saying
and you don't feel good about it go hey
i can't do that right now i got a
full-time gig and i can only do so many
cakes i'm so sorry i would have loved to
get a cake for you i can't do it
or then get over the fact that you're
cutting your prices
if you feel which one makes you feel
worse selling them a cake at 350
or selling the cake at 150 and doing the
work of a 350 cake for a 150k
which which is worse for you oh good
question
i know that's why i do what i do i
haven't done the i haven't turned down
one yet
because they get excited they're like
they know me and they're like ooh
i have the perfect cake for this person
for their birthday's coming up and they
they want to be
generous they want to be nice and do
something well you just answered
you would rather steeply discount your
pricing to make these people feel good
so if that's kind of a ministry for you
uh
i'm thinking that yeah yeah yeah i was
wondering can i look at it like that
like
of course you can look at it like that
but i wondered if that was just
i don't want to be like the cop out like
well this is what i do for a living and
i think that's the thing that
women especially tend to do is like well
i'll just give away my work no
don't do that you know now listen i'm
telling you not to undervalue it's their
problem if they can't afford it
i run into people all the time that do
something amazing how much does that
cost
and they tell me i'm like well that's
not going to happen for me
right let me ask you this question
people would say that let me ask you
this question samantha all right
and you probably already said this so if
you said this i apologize but are you
debt free right now
i did not pay it but i am except for my
mortgage except for your mortgage so
you have a fully funded emergency fund
yes
okay cool and again this may be an
unpopular opinion
but i i still think you're doing a
ministry at 350
per k you know now if you want to go
down a little bit lower that's fine but
i don't want to say you're doing more
ministry or it
is a ministry because your your cakes
are a little bit cheaper
you know i i still think you still have
a great ministry at 350 dollars
that's ministry into my home do you long
term samantha want to have your own
thing or is this always just going to be
something fun on the side for you
yeah it's a good question probably just
on the side
yeah well then you get to decide you get
to decide a who you do a cake for and be
what you price it at stop overthinking
it
stop feeling guilty if you're okay
discounting your cake prices for people
that you know
uh or friends of friends who can't
afford your normal price then be fine
with that
but if you also feel like it's too much
you can't serve the whole world it's not
your problem that they can't afford your
cake
you got to stop taking all this on you
but at the same time you got an amazing
heart and that's why you do this and ken
if she discounts those price
she can't say well you know it's worth
350 dollars yeah
you can't get upset about it exactly
that's right you gotta get
uh but if you'd like to send one of
those cakes anthony and i we would uh be
happy to sample that
and uh you said sample i was about to
say ain't paying 350
an okay yes yeah yeah exactly neither am
i
but that's just because we don't value
that but hey good stuff hey thank you
for the call samantha you are a great
lady you're doing great stuff
love it all right folks don't move more
of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neal and we're taking your
questions about your life your work your
money your relationships
hey you want to move up the ladder i'd
love
to help you figure out how to get
promoted hey you got some relationship
stuff and money
especially if you're single ao is on
call
ready to go and we are here to help you
triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey uh
big news
uh the entre leadership summit 2022
has been launched it has been announced
the dates
and here we go it's going to be may 22nd
through 25
may 22-25 2022 that's at the hyatt
regency orlando in orlando florida
i will be joining that speaker lineup of
course dave ramsey chrissy wright dr
john deloney jamie kern lima
the founder of it cosmetics jaylen a
long time host
of the tonight show will godard who's
one of the top
american restaurateurs jade simmons a
classical concert pianist dr henry cloud
best-selling author of boundaries and
pat lencioni the best-selling author of
ideal team players if you're a business
owner or senior leader
and you want to be in the room and grow
the entre leadership summit is a
fantastic event if you'd like to
register
text the word summit two four four
two two two text the word summit that's
two m's
two four four two two two that's
four four two two two
all right all those numbers i'm all
confused triple eight eight two five
five two two five i know that's the
number to call in
let's go to newtown or newton i'm not
sure how you say that i'll say newtown
we'll take a guess there
caroline joins us caroline how can we
help
hi um i have a question about baby step
four
okay go ahead so i so i my husband and i
make 165k a year but we
pay um 37 000
a year in day care expenses for our
children
and fifteen thousand dollars a year in
um health care benefits
so that so i didn't know if we take
the if we take fifteen percent out of
our income
after our take-home income it's like 23
of our take-home income and i wasn't
sure if you take
large high day care expenses into
account
uh what do you mean what do you mean
hold on help me out here
break this down again you're paying your
your household income is 165
000 a year correct gross
okay gross all right cool so baby step
number four is you're going to
invest 15 of your
gross income and either into a 401k
or a roth ira or a roth 401k
so then after you make that investment
then
you pay your bills and so your day care
just goes inside of your normal budget
from whatever you have after your net
pay
now your health care should be coming
out of your check automatically
through y'all's employer or are you
self-employed
no the the health care costs do come out
of our paycheck
okay cool but our day care costs are 28
of our
income right but what anthony's saying
is it doesn't matter what baby step four
is is you're taking 15
of your income and you're investing that
towards retirement it has nothing to do
with daycare
yeah and your daycare that's an expense
that you and your husband sign up for
so it's just like me i have a golf
expense i
chose that expense um and so i think
what you've got to do is just go ahead
and take 15
out and then also after that you gotta
add your daycare to your budget
and that's a part of it okay yeah thank
you
thank you for the call yeah absolutely
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to paula who
joins us now in oklahoma city oklahoma
paula how can we help
hi paula how are you guys doing today we
are living the dream what are you doing
out living the dream also quick question
for you
both of you because you guys are two of
my favorite uh ramsey personalities of
course
um so i do coaching and staff developing
for a child care corporation
and um i received a recent offer
um about and it
comes out to about ten thousand dollars
more
than what the offer is of what i make
right
now now my dilemma is
that i do travel from my company i live
in oklahoma city but i do travel for my
company
and so um and so the travel would be
it's it would be really a lateral move
like the insurance would basically be
the same
um the um you know the only thing that
will be different would be the pay
and then let me say this i would lose my
company car
that i did that i do drive um because
it's a lot more
travel to um states
that um we have we have
schools in in the states that i live in
but
it would be a lot more travel as far as
more
far away travel because i i do fly some
but sometimes you know it's just easier
just to jump in the car and drive by the
time you get to the airport
waiting two hours you know that kind of
thing sure okay so
um which job the only thing it'd really
be a lateral move
with a pay increase but the thing is
also
i love my job i'm not unhappy okay so
that's the only question i have
all this money stuff it's basically a
wash i never make a decision
in my work about money it's always about
meaning because again if i'm doing work
that i love that produces a result that
i care
deeply about i call that passion and
mission then
i will i will adjust my lifestyle and
i'm going to be very happy
so the current job you're in you love it
does not sound like we got that emotion
for this new offer correct
right and i i mean i would love to do
this as well
um and then but this is another question
i have for you
um ken not to leave you out of the
conversation anthony that's okay
but but this is what you know another
question is
so because of the travel because
at least when i'm in oklahoma i can like
maybe a couple times
you know maybe every other month every
three months i work in our schools in
oklahoma
this would be total um you know
mostly travel away um and so
i wouldn't be in oklahoma as much and so
i'm
you know i'm and i'm only home on the
weekends like i'm traveling now i'm
driving home now
um from you know and i'm homing home on
the weekends anyway
but i was wondering let me ask you this
if i if because of this new position
could i even negotiate some more time at
home
with this new job if i i'd even keep the
same pay that i have if maybe
i had like three days of a month out you
know
that i could be home during maybe but
paula paul you got
you got to stop stop giving me all these
reasons
okay listen listen you love your current
job
yeah right you're trying to talk
yourself into this other job
and if you take it unless i'm missing
something
you're not super excited about this this
new job offer
or this new job offer doesn't offer you
this unbelievable ladder if it's true
you haven't told me yet so that's the
two-part question
do you love the work that you'll be
doing in the new job
at a and then b will it lead you up the
ladder that you want to climb
yes it will yes to both of those
so you will so you will love the new job
yeah oh absolutely well then i don't
know what we're talking about take the
new job
well i just i i don't want to be
motivated you know i know
money is not a motivator for me either
well wait a second
i know that you already said that it was
basically a wash because
they're paying you 10 000 more but
you're gonna lose the company car so
that's a real expense for you so
you said it was a wash not me here's the
deal if it is a
if it is a good opportunity for you to
move up the ladder
meaning can you move up the ladder
faster and better with the new job
versus the current job yes or no
yes well this is this conversation is
over paula stop thinking about it
take the job and yes if you want to ask
them if you can
be home a little bit more fine they've
offered you the job certainly can
mention
it we don't demand it we just ask
uh but you're just over analyzing this
and folks let me just and again i'm not
picking on paula
listen all of us overthink
break it down i'll speak for you brother
i don't know will i love the work
will the work the offer allow me to move
up where i want to go the answer is
yes and yes stop thinking start doing
my goodness if god kicks a door open i
don't go god are you sure
all right don't move oh ramsey show
coming right up
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Applause]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsey show
we're coming to you live from our ramsay
solutions
world headquarters in nashville i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neal and oh it's our favorite
part of the show ao as i look
through the glass oh boy
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stray stage rather
is tracy hi tracy how are you hi ken how
are you
telling you we're having a blast so now
where do you live i live in columbia
south carolina
all right so drove in yes drove in
originally from memphis tennessee
all right so we got tennessee gal here
yes sir do you know how to make really
good barbecue oh you know i do come on
i'm telling you i just had a feeling
when you said memphis because that is
where the good stuff is
awesome so how much debt did you pay off
so i paid off thirty six thousand
five hundred and twenty two dollars wow
and how long did it take it took about
14 months
14 months and what was your range of
income during that time
i made about 79 000. wow what do you do
i am a master sergeant in the united
states air force oh
well thank you for your service you are
a great american
thank you thank you i enjoy what i do
currently um i'm stationed at shaw air
force base
i'm the superintendent of the financial
management directorate
at the ninth air force okay well thank
you so much that is so
awesome uh what type of debt was it so
half of it was student loans
and then the other half was credit cards
oh so you were super normal
super normal yes oh i love it okay so
what happened when did it happen for you
to go all right i'm gonna knock this out
so so how it started how my
uh financial peace journey started was
um i had a first sergeant who introduced
me
to financial peace he came he came up to
me and just told me his story
he invited me to his church to see what
fpu was about
i joined went to the next fpu class i
think it was 12 weeks
we went through everything i learned the
um
all the tools it took to become
debt-free
but i was davish the whole time just you
know doing
i knew i didn't want any more loans i
didn't want any more
credit cards but uh january of
2020 i got promoted so i was super
excited
but i still had that gloom of debt over
me
yeah and i was like i'm not doing this
anymore so i vowed january of 2020 that
any
extra penny was going towards
debt i was going to you know work
that every dollar app every night
and just make sure my money was going
where it's it's supposed to be going to
get out of it
i love that now what church are you a
member of in columbia
so in colombia i'm a member of shannon
baptist church okay okay
okay and did you take fpu there no i
took
fpu at in wichita falls texas at first
baptist church oh okay
i was stationed in texas yeah we know
exactly about that church a very
very very good church so what did it
take uh throughout this year and two
months to get out of debt
so it took you know i love to travel so
that's where most of my money
was going to i love i have a large
family we love to just get up and go
so it took just being um
intentional okay um and making sure
that you know my money was going where
it was supposed to go
yeah yeah um not eating out as much
that was that was a big thing for my
family is not eating out as
much so okay okay who are your biggest
cheerleaders
so my biggest cheerleaders were my
family um
first my mom my mom has been my support
system
for a long time forever so my mom was my
biggest cheerleader
my oldest daughter tayla ava aubrey and
alana
those were you know a huge part of my
fan base but my mentors
um any every one of my mentors i let
them know what my goals were
financially and each one of them always
checked up on me to make sure that i was
still getting after those goals even
though life was still happening
so tracy i'm looking at the math right
i'm just going to ask you straight
forward i want you to bless somebody
yes were close to forty thousand dollars
in debt yes
making eighty thousand dollars in income
i'm going to assume
that you're a single mother and i see
three
four four little girls four beautiful
beautiful queens out there
yes and so that means 50
of your income went towards paying off
debt absolutely and then you have a lot
of people saying if i got all these kids
i can't do this on my own
one here's a question how did you do
that then two
what was the hardest thing throughout
this journey
in the process of getting out of debt so
how did i do it i brought them along the
journey i let them know
what i was trying to do wow so just
making sure um
they would you know sit with me and and
you know as i'm trying to decide on
purchasing something they're like no mom
you know
we're we're trying to um become
debt-free remember that
let's put that to the side let's wait on
that let's hold off on that so
um which one was that because one of
them back there laughing
so all of them probably laugh
ava ava is you know she she she'll come
and sit next to me
yes yes i love it what were the
conversations beyond the specifics of
those decisions that
that kind of came out of that as your
these young ladies are watching their
mother
uh take on a monumental task so the
conversations about just
college because i had to explain to them
why i had that
student loan debt what student loans are
um
so the conversations they came out of is
that you can get scholarships you can
get grants you can pay your way through
college you
don't have to go into debt no you lying
so lying around that was uh yeah
what was one of the toughest things or
biggest sacrifices in this journey
oh one of the toughest things um
was like i said travel just sitting
still
sitting sitting still and knowing that
knowing to live like no other today so i
can live and give like no other
so um just just being still and knowing
that
i won't be in debt forever this process
won't be going on forever so
see that's very interesting because you
love travel it's a big part of your
family
uh memories and experiences it's kind of
like this is an expectation this is what
we do
so is it was it worth it to put off
those trips and how beautiful is it
going to be when you get on that next
trip
absolutely it was worth every every
minute every moment everything that
we've learned
my our money means so much more to us
now
yeah so you got another trip planned not
quite yet
yeah but but we're we're going you're
thinking about it yes absolutely
on our way um back home we're going to
go through memphis to visit granddaddy's
i have a fun question is uh
if god brings the right man is marriage
in your future oh man
that's a good one absolutely i am
absolutely ready to get married so tracy
now listen uh
don't don't let no knucklehead come in
there you worked hard yes
that's right you don't work hard he
needs to come here working double hard
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah all right tell him
to get his stuff in order before you
even
let him put a ring on it exactly you
know what i mean tell him you got two
brothers over here
yeah a brother and a vanilla brother
that can't go back i appreciate that
i appreciate the vanilla because i
thought you're going to say pale
i haven't been out in the sun yet this
year and uh so i uh but i appreciate the
vanilla i'll take that
all right so we got the ladies with us
right we got the girls we got
tayla ava aubry and alana did i say that
right come on up are they going to do
this
and my mother oh my mother this is uh
evangeline hardaway but my kids call her
bye-bye
we got to do this i'm assuming tracy
that they've been rehearsing
oh yeah because they got the matching
outfits the dresses they look lovely
look at those girls
come on in squeeze on in all right
everybody in
and uh all right so is everybody ready
and we got mama in there there she is
she's look at that smile she's proud
that's great all right so here we go if
everybody's ready we got
tracy who paid off 36
000 in 14 months making 79
000 she's joined on stage by mama tayla
ava
aubry and alana let's hear your
debt-free scream
one two three we're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is holding that note out too i
like that ao
she sings in the choir you get to hold
that notes
oh that is so awesome you know tracy you
inspire so many people
absolutely thank you for sharing your
story with us a single mom can do it
you can do it absolutely love that story
thank you tracy and girls and mama for
sharing
that journey with us all right we're
gonna go out and celebrate with them
don't move more ramsay show coming right
around the corner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsey show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague anthony o'neil we're so
excited that you're with us as we take
your calls
about your life your money your mission
and your work your relationships we are
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five
you know ken before we go to uh dan um i
really wanted to just
just make sure that we just highlight
what just happened yeah
i don't wanna fly by that this was a
single mother of four
tracy kids tracy yeah right um from
columbia south carolina
who lived off of about 30 thousand
dollars
in one year i want to hear this i want
y'all to hear this
she lived off of 30 000 in income
with four kids as a single mother so she
could pay off
nearly 40 000 yes so when y'all call in
here with these excuses and you don't
have any kids
and you make fifty thousand dollars a
year forty thousand dollars a year you
tell me you can't pay off thirty
thousand dollars
uh-oh i'm gonna be like dave hush up
because i mean if you see what she can
do yeah
then there's no excuses the greatest
enemy to our success
is our excuse if you genuinely and truly
want to do it
you will shut up with the excuses and go
after it yeah
so i just wanted to highlight that tracy
is my hero and then when we went out
there kim what did she say i just
graduated master class so she can go out
there and teach other people yeah she's
a financial coach just finished our
financial coach master training
uh if you missed it last segment go
check it out the podcast
over here on youtube rewind it that's
why we do the debt free screams is so
that you can hear the journeys
of others and be inspired uh to overcome
your own challenges
i love that you called it out and on top
of that serving our country in the air
force
uh just a phenomenal phenomenal lady and
what a joy it was to meet those
beautiful little girls
uh i will tell you the youngest one
could have co-hosted the show she really
she has so much personality we should
have brought her in here and had her
done a segment with us it would have
been the best segment in the history of
the show
she is uh just such a fun fun fun little
gal so good stuff
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to scranton
pennsylvania where dan
joins us dan how can we help uh hi ken
and anthony i'm actually calling from
german pennsylvania the birthplace of
first aid
oh fantastic i thank you guys for your
financial first aid and ken for your
career first aid and ao for your
educational first aid
well thank you sir how can we help you
today uh my wife and i are in baby step
two
when we began our total money makeover
last july
we put our second mortgage into baby
step six uh but now with our income
plus uh the minimum payments that we
made on our second mortgage we're
wondering if we should put it into baby
step two
uh when you say second mortgage what
what kind of mortgage did you take out
um it was uh it was a it was a mortgage
we were it was going to be a home equity
loan um
bank yeah yeah yeah so if it is
something like that then yes you're
going to go ahead and add that into baby
step number two
okay so your primary your primary
mortgage we're going ahead and stay
in baby step six uh but anything extra
that you took out yes that that's debt i
mean well actually it's all dead
uh but i do want you go ahead and add
that in babysit number two yeah thank
you for the call
dan all right let's see abel is up next
in seattle washington abel how can we
help
how are you guys doing uh shout out to
tracy for paying off our day hopefully i
could get there too
yeah you can you can yeah so right now
i'm upside down on my car
i make about 24 an hour it's like 50 000
a year
and i just needed help just getting out
of this
okay what kind of car is it man uh 2018
mcbc okay yeah mitsubishi uh how much do
you owe on it
uh 24 000 and i wrote some negative
equity on to it also
oh lord jesus how much do you um
how much is it worth the birth about
17 16. low are we in the problem
okay what other what other kind of debt
do you have
right now i have no credit cards luckily
um
student loans i do have student loans
student loans that are in department
how much are those um uh it's about
50 50k okay
all right all right what else you got
man um that's
really about it i'm about to get a raise
in about two to three years and it's
gonna make me go up to about 80 to 90 a
year
all right okay cool great cool great
cool cool cool all right so here's the
thing
cars worth seventeen thousand dollars
you owe twenty four thousand dollars on
it because you
wrote in negative equity um do you have
any cash in your savings right now
just a thousand dollars i've been
watching you guys for the past
like months like religiously so i'm
rocking with you i'm rocking with you
okay cool
um how long would it take you to save up
five grand
so i'll say about six months six months
you make fifty thousand dollars a year
i also own a home with my life um okay
and i pay about 1200.
what is your wife other side of the
mortgage she makes
about 80. okay so everybody yeah now
we're at one thirty
got rid of one thirty yeah bro uh uh uh
hold on
and um so between 1 30
it'll take you six months to get five
thousand dollars
well she also has her own credit card
debt and
student loans that she's paying and we
just got married so we're trying to
find a way to balance our finances all
right well
well we have we have two questions we
have two things we need to address
um it sounds like y'all are not
combining everything together
uh i'll let i'll let our married god
talk about that i'm a single guy talk to
the single people so i'll let him talk
about well i'll just i'll jump in very
quick cause ao can get you out of this
and tell you what you need to do but
abel here's what we teach when you're
married it's it's our debt
it's not her credit cards it's not her
student loans it's hours
yeah so you know you're still in a
mindset and that's okay we're not
criticizing you but
this is this is this is leaving cleave
and and i don't know what your wedding
vows were but
we're joining together and it's not just
because of what we believe about
marriage it's because we've got to be on
the same page to get out of this debt
or this is going to become bigger than a
money problem this will be a marriage
problem i can guarantee you that
so you started off the call going i make
50. we didn't even know about the wife
we didn't know what she makes no this is
how this goes so you need to give
ao the new number starting with we
make a combined income of 130 000. we
have total debts including whatever
mama's debts are that you just married
all right so i'd start over and then ao
can walk you through this but this is a
combined
situation here yeah real quick so what
do you say combined income
total debt you all have combined income
for the household is 130 i would say
combined debt
now would have to be about 100.
okay all right cool great so there's
going to you're going to work the death
snowball man have you taken financial
peace university inside of ramsey plus
you and you win i have the app i have
that i have the app
i have i haven't got anything else i
just have the dollar app every dollar
app
okay cool great this is what we're gonna
do i'm gonna have you stand online
madison's gonna give you and your wife
a free year subscription on ken and i on
ramsay plus to get you all in it
here's what i really want you to do i
want you to consider selling the car
okay you're gonna take out a loan for
the difference of whatever you do not
and cannot sell it for
so let's say for an example you sell it
for 17 that means you're negative 7
000. you're gonna take out a loan for
seven thousand dollars
yes i am saying take out a loan why
because you're going from 24 000
in debt down to 7 000 debt in that car
all right the reason why i said save up
5k because i'm going to take 5k
and go pay cash for a car you lower your
debt
you don't have a a monthly payment and
then what you got to do is you got to
really work the debt
snowball because now let's say for an
example the car was the only thing that
you had
with 130 000 income i'll say yo let's
get very aggressive with attacking the
car but right
now if we can get this thing down to
seven thousand dollars
or five thousand if you sell it cash um
then i i love that math because we lower
our
debt and then also we pay cash for a car
temporary and then once you and your
wife become debt free get a fully funded
emergency fund
then you can go back out there and buy
you a better car cash but i want you to
stay on the line
uh madison's going to take good care of
you i want you and your wife
to go through this class together so
y'all pick a date night
um and y'all just go through this
together and i promise you're going to
learn a lot from
ken myself dave rachel um and our entire
team here man but uh
such a great question and that's
something that i've been teaching you
know uh singles like when we do get
married it is we
so if i get married and my wife has debt
man i y'all may see me on the debt free
scream stage one day because now
i'm back in debt so don't don't tell
people this because
you ain't going to marry some woman
that's got dead i know you i don't know
no i can't say all of that no i'm saying
if god you're so particular
that looks good with twenty five
thousand dollars in that problem
though we gonna pay that debt off in
like two months so james real quick
i can't be in debt i hate that hey abel
you can do this you guys got a combined
income to be able to do this and you can
actually go out and make some more money
you need to get gazelle intense do
what we teach you in financial peace all
right i want to thank our producer james
childs our social producer today madison
browder and
my colleague ao and you america this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
[Music]
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your money your work your legacy your
relationships
and if ao has anything to do with it
well that's single life
trying to do it right he's raring and
ready to go today anthony o'neil my
colleague joins me
this hour nice talk man give us a call i
want to help hey seriously
money and being single this guy is
having a great conversation about
the single life making good life
decisions not just money decisions
over on the table with anthony o'neil
this thing is a runaway hit
over on youtube i've never been on the
show because i'm married apparently
and uh so i'm still waiting on my invite
uh but no he's doing great stuff over
there please make sure you join it
uh he's on youtube search the table with
anthony o'neil also
uh on your favorite podcast app as well
and uh don't forget the ken coleman show
we spent
hours and hours coming up with that name
a lot of creativity poured into that ao
as you know
and you can check it out where you
listen to podcasts your talk radio
station
siriusxm and youtube triple eight eight
two five
five two two five is the phone number to
jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to the city
of angels los angeles california where
mike joins us mike how can we help
hi ken and anthony it's a honor to be
speaking with you guys and thank you for
having me on your show you bet what's up
so my question is and i'll get straight
to the point is
do i have uh is it possible to have too
much money in my emergency fund
and if so what should i do with that
money should i invest it should i
dump it into my mortgage i'm just uh
kind of
want to get your opinions on what i
should do with that yeah man
yes there are there will be times and
there can be times when you have
too much money in your emergency fund we
want our money to grow
as much as possible but then we also
want to make sure we have enough money
liquid uh to protect us from emergencies
that may come up
um and to protect us from going back
into debt so
um what how much money do you have in
your savings account right now
mike 75 000 okay cool great all right
do you have any debt right now i have no
debt except my mortgage
okay cool great and uh you're in la so
what would you say
is three to six well what do you do for
a living let me ask you that for that
question first mike
i work for the government okay and what
would you say your annual income is
uh approximately 150 000 a year okay
150k a year how do you
mike i am 41 years old 41. you got that
money okay cool
what's your investment portfolio look
like right now are you investing 15
of your uh income yes sir i am uh i have
putting
at least 15 towards retirement between
my 457b
plan and my roth ira so at 40 i'm
curious how much money do you have in
your investments
just short of 300 000 oh man you're
living good you're
you're living good like man i just love
it i'm just asking questions well he
wasn't always like this i made a lot of
mistakes when i was young hey man you
and i both and i'm still young and
you're still young let's be real like
kenzo but you and i
we uh
i can't wait till you turn 40 man i'm
gonna just rash you
so hard but hey seriously um
mike what is some of your goals are do
you own a home right now
i do own a home okay cool and um what
what
how much do you own at home uh i owe
approximately 430 000. 430k
all right cool um and what is it worth
close to a million dollars oh yeah man
man i'm liking you right now brother
uh i like you uh and you said you're
married are you single
i am single uh oh ladies no kids no no
no
kids at 40. no sir oh you know you're a
great candidate i need to get you on my
show
here we go i can have him hooked up uh
by tomorrow afternoon guy calls for
financial advice and ao's gonna get him
married i
love it here's here's my advice man um
you're already investing 15
um you're already living below your
means clearly um i would take that 75
000
and invest that into your home i will go
ahead and jump over to baby step number
six because we're going to skip over
babysit number five
because you don't have any kids if i
invest 75 000 that won't leave me any
uh money into my uh emergency fund i
didn't say 75 so i would say i said i
would take
some of the 75 and invest it into your
home yeah and so with you working for
the government
um whatever you comfortable with if i
was you i'm gonna i'm gonna leave
three months in the account because you
have a very stable job with the
government
uh and so i would take the rest of that
and going ahead and
invest that into the home and bro i
would just really start attacking your
home if you're already doing 15
uh there's really no reason why to start
doing more you're young 300
000 in the account within your
investments you can leave about
you know 20 to 25 000 inside of your
emergency fund put 50k towards your
mortgage
that's going to bring you below 400 with
your kind of
income and your dedication you can be
completely debt free on to babysit
number seven building wealth and giving
very generously uh within the next three
years and so i will i will go ahead and
attack it maybe four years
uh but um i'll go ahead and attack i
might jump in here uh
and and i'm stepping into ao territory
here okay
but he's he's single you said he's a
prime candidate if he goes and gets
himself an anthony o'neil woman debt
free and she's got the double income
they could pay that house off even
faster
absolutely so i just that's how we juice
this
so you're trying to say pay off the
house but also go get you a woman
who's debt free and working who's debt
who's debt free and working and so we
pay it off even faster
i mean i can't sit next to you when i'm
going
hey this is how you get it done faster
trust me i'm thinking the same thing but
i mean it's it's
this dating world out here and and
correct me if i mean
bro it's hard it's hard out here for us
you're saying that you're saying it's uh
you've been off the market for what 20
years 23 23 years it's night and day
from 20.
very much thank you very much 23 years i
don't even know what it would be like
like i shudder at the thought of that do
you know what i mean like
it's a minefield is what you're telling
me well i don't want to disrespect the
ladies out there but it
you don't have to it is difficult okay
if if you're a good person good man or
woman it is difficult to find a good
opposition do you
think that you know okay oh look
this is good this is good do you think a
guy like mike
yeah who's 41 debt free
you know you know is he a target is he a
target
for for you know this isn't all about
women but the point is the same thing
same thing with women if they're debt
free are they targets for loser dudes
who are trying to kind of take advantage
of them because they're so so
financially stable does that happen
again i am not the relationship
personality or relationship expert
no but you're the single man yeah who's
in good shape overseas
he believe it or not mike is not the
target
because i think a young lady will look
at him and say if you're this guy
why are you still single so there will
be questions
up front now once they get those
questions answered oh they're going to
love that's what i'm saying the security
oh yeah so you got to be careful is what
i'm saying absolutely you don't want to
take on a bunch of debt a bunch of
craziness
yeah yeah you can take on some debt yeah
all right if it's the right person but
you don't want to take on crazy who's
looking at you as a
kid but ken you got to stop saying that
single people debt-free can't date
someone with debt i didn't say that oh
okay
i'm not saying anything okay first of
all i am not in the business telling
anybody who they can date
okay that's not my that's not my thing
i'm just saying you have to be careful
you do have to be careful you gotta be
wise you gotta make sure that her or his
money
uh mindset is on the same as yours uh
but mike man that's that that's a solid
one right there ladies y'all need to i
need to youtube him
look him up on instagram find him say i
heard you on the ramsay show
poor mike is now going on all of his
social media channels and changing his
name
uh hey mike great job uh man you are
crushing it you are on your way to being
really really wealthy
i really appreciate the call good stuff
all right don't go anywhere
anthony o'neil ken coleman sitting in on
this hour of the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions studios in nashville
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neil we're taking your
calls about your life whether you want
to
move up the ladder in your career and
make some more money
uh or you get those money questions or
again when it was here we're having some
fun today you
you're single and trying to figure out
the money situation and the relationship
equation we got ao there
for you as well but hey before we get to
the phones
uh when it comes to making big money or
big life moves like buying a home
getting married having a baby
the last thing on your mind when you're
thinking about those big decisions
is the right insurance coverage and we
understand that
those big changes are overwhelming but
it would be even more overwhelming to
find yourself in a situation where you
or your family weren't covered properly
if not having the time or energy is
what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage we got that
covered
use one of our endorsed local provider
or elp insurance agents to help
our elps are independent agents who find
you the best coverage at the best
price free of charge that's right an
independent agent shops
a variety of options finding you the
best and explains all the technical
lingo so you know exactly what you're
getting for free all you have to do is
text the word
insurance to 33789 that's
insurance text that word to three three
seven eight nine
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number back to the phones we
go
gina joins us in boston massachusetts
gina how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure
um so my question is if it will take me
a while to pay off my student loans
should i par start putting at least
something into a 401k
now as opposed to waiting a couple years
and having nothing in there
so jeannie let me ask you this question
what do you think you should do
honestly uh
well i'm not sure that's why i'm calling
okay um
i i understand yeah i just want to if
you had to put if you had to do a
your own little thought what would you
do my own
i guess i would put like some something
there so that
it's not at zero when i'm done with all
the debt but
um another factor in is that
um my company my publishing house was
just
bought by a different publishing house
so we have a different 401k
plan now and now they are giving us 25
of whatever we put into our 401k
which is not the situation before cool
so
so now people are telling me that i'm
throwing away money if i'm not putting
anything into the 401k
um because i wasn't doing that before um
so i have about 51 000 in loans
um and i'm just i i don't know
which way to go do you have any other
debt or is it just the 51 000 in student
loans
just just the student loans i graduated
with 83 000 and i've paid off 32. good
for you how much money are you making
jim
um well my my salary is 36 000 but my
take-home pay is about 24.
okay great wow you're really crushing it
yeah you really are yeah i'm trying
yeah now are you living with family or
friends or are you living on your own
gina
i was for i've been out of school for
two years
and i was living with my parents and
just this month i moved into my own
apartment so
that was another factor of okay i can't
spend
as much as before but it just felt like
it was time to be out of my parents
house and
be on my own what's your scheduled
payoff date if everything goes
as is when do you expect to be done with
the 51 000
um well if i keep doing the minimum
payment
it says 13 years um but that's not what
you've been doing
right right that that's not what i've
been doing
um but i haven't
this is a great question i guess i
haven't figured out because i've only
been in my new apartment for a month
and i've never been out on my own before
i'm only 25.
um and so i guess i need to figure out
how much extra i need to be giving to my
loans now that i can
come board yeah that's the first thing
you need to figure out how long it's
going to take you
based on gazelle intensity you work in a
second job is maybe an option
uh how long is it going to take you to
pay off the 51 000 you're asking anthony
a question
on the 401k and you don't even have a
good idea how long it's actually going
to take it's not going to take you 13
years
i mean you you crushed it i know you
were you're living with your parents
but the reality is is that you were
gazelle intense and you've already
knocked off you know 30 plus thousand if
i remember correctly
and so if you get after this at the age
of 25
you can knock this out a lot quicker
than you think so let's start with that
number and try to figure that out and
then ao
why should she not uh start investing in
her 401k why are her friends and all
these advisors
wrong well i'm gonna tell you why
because that 13 years is going to turn
into about 20 years
um and here's the thing a lot of people
think well if i could put in because
what we see is when you have debt
you're only going to invest about one to
three percent of your income because
you're trying to get another one and
three percent
uh with the match and i'd understand the
thinking
uh but what i do not understand is well
why would you want to put an extra
100 200 over there when you can put that
same 100 200
over here and get out of debt quicker
when you get out of that
quicker instead of you investing one to
three percent
you're investing 15 so not only would
you catch up you were surpassed
where you thought you could have been if
you just honestly follow the baby steps
so what i'm what i'm telling you is
machina is
i wouldn't worry about investing and
missing out because what we're teaching
you is
not just how to uh invest and build
wealth
today we're teaching how to get out of
debt so when you do build wealth
you can continue building wealth and
building a lot of it
and so what i would encourage you to do
is i
i want ken to talk before we go to break
real quick so i'm gonna shut up
do not invest into the 401k i want you
to get on
the debt snowball and put all of your
extra income
towards that now i want to challenge you
bringing home 24 000
a year that is low so we need to figure
out how to get you an extra part-time
job
so you can put at least ten thousand
dollars towards your student loans
and that'll go from 13 years to five
years about five years in a couple of
months but it's gonna
save you about ten thousand dollars in
interest so ken is there anything we
could do to get an extra 10 000
yeah a year well there's a couple ways
to do it i think the i think the uh
part-time job and making some additional
money and even if you can do it in your
particular field that you're in
to get some additional experience you've
got this expertise you're out of school
a lot of times people think well i gotta
go drive uber well that's certainly a
possibility or any other part-time job
delivering pizza whatever it is
but sometimes we forget to look for
opportunities in our field
that get us that valuable experience
i've already got this expertise i've
gone to school for this i'm in this
field
and could i offer that in other places
where you can call it consulting or
whatever you want to call it but it'll
be contract work
where you can really rack up some money
and i would continue uh
to do what anthony said which is just
put every extra dime you've got
into this and then there's going to be
plenty of time for you to invest
but right now the reason we don't want
you skipping the baby steps
is because we want all of that money
getting you out of debt
and then you will catch up you're
actually not going to miss
out if it takes you three years and i
think you could pay off the 50 and three
or less i really believe that because
we're not even taking into account
you're in your first job essentially or
early
on the ladder and you getting a
promotion i'd like to see you making 50
60 000 what is it what needs to be true
for you to get promoted
and then the additional job i actually
think someone of your age
and pay off that 51 000 in three years
or less i really believe that
um and then the amount of money that
you're supposedly leaving on the table
you're going to catch up all of that
absolutely because you have no debt
and you're still going to be in your
late 20s i mean i'm looking at a 27
28 year old pale i think you're that old
i think you're 25 now i think you can do
this
the question is is how intense do you
want to get
and when we preach gazelle intensity
let's give you the image here we're
talking about
this little deer this deerish animal
that is
running for its life we're not talking
about a competition we're talking about
survival yes and it's being
it's it's got a cheetah running after it
right or a lion or whatever
you've got to run for your life on this
and if you do this i think you'd be
shocked how quickly you could pay off 51
000.
so good ken you preaching today ken well
you know i'm next to the preacher i'm a
preacher's son
so you know you put me in this situation
where you get preaching and then i start
preaching and then what are we doing man
we're just we need to take an offer
you know what we got a good band i mean
music director
and our producer from james james
child's a world-class engineer producer
songwriter this guy i don't know we
should we we do need to
pass the plate it wouldn't go over well
it'd be the last time we did it but it
would be fun
i'm kidding hey you do realize
this show is free more of your free
advice
right around the corner this is the
ramsey show
let's start playing some cup
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsay solutions studios
in nashville thrilled to have you with
us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague anthony o'neil and we are
taking
your calls triple eight eight two five
five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five hey this is your last
weekend to shop our famous ten dollar
sale
learn how to make faster and real
progress with your money
and in your career when you check out
our famous ten dollar sale you can save
up to sixty percent on
over 40 best-selling books and budgeting
tools like my proximity principle and
anthony o'neill's newly
designed book the graduate survival
guide don't forget
his number one best seller debt free
degree as well
all of these books make for great gifts
shop our 10 sale
at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com plus
this is also your last weekend to enter
to win our ramsey cash
giveaway we're giving away the grand
prize of five thousand dollars in cash
this week enter daily for extra chances
to win
no purchase necessary you must be 18 or
older to win
text the word cash to 33789
text cash to 33789 to enter our giveaway
now all right let's go back to the
phones joshua is
on the line in louisville kentucky
joshua how can we help
hello joshua all right
well here oh there we go there we go
sorry i'm sorry
the kids were talking about i get it no
worries how can we help
yeah my uh hopefully a quick question my
uh my wife and i have an opportunity to
uh take on a well sort of staff position
with the church
part of that includes housing on on
campus because
sort of part of the function would be to
you know keep an eye on the plays take
care of things around the
around the church things like that um
and so that's part of this base of the
compensation is housing
uh so right now we own our own home
we've been here for
about two and a half years now and so
we've got a little bit of equity but uh
but the housing market in our area is up
quite a bit so we would make some money
off the sale um
but we're my wife is kind of attached to
the house uh since it's our first home
and so she so we're wondering whether or
not it would be beneficial for us to
uh simply just sell the house and be out
from under it take and pay off most of
our debt with what we make or
turn into a rental property so one of
you guys can get some planners on that
well let's be honest it's absolutely
beneficial for you to sell the house
financially because you just told us you
you're gonna pay off
uh all of your debt or most of your debt
is that how i heard that
uh a majority of it uh right now we've
got uh it's just under eight fifty
thousand dollars uh the vast majority of
student loans we've got a couple
thousand dollars in
um uh miscellaneous debt and then uh
credit card
uh actually the vast majority student
loans um
the and like so right now we owe about
i think 116 roughly on the mortgage the
real
agent is pretty sure we can sell for
around 160.
um so after fees and everything we're
probably looking at about 40 grand yeah
i mean that is
hardly clear so just think about how
that fast forwards your debt-free
journey and then you're gonna knock off
the other stuff because you've got
reduced expenses with the church housing
so all of a sudden you're in great shape
and and if you're looking at renting
uh to try to rent this thing you're just
not gonna clear enough let's run those
numbers
give ao and i the numbers if you rent it
what would you rent it for and what's
your mortgage payment
uh well i'm working right now with a
thousand just under a thousand
um i think it's like 950 960 something
like that with ensure with culinary
insurance
okay um the uh i think the
estimates according to a couple numbers
we ran was about 13
monthly for uh you know for a rental
cost
yeah and then on top of that you got
repairs and stuff you got to deal with
as now
being a landlord so you tell me which is
the best financial situation
well i'm i'm definitely leaning towards
selling uh my wife is
like i said she's she's really attached
to the house next week because it's our
house
together we had our newest kid here and
so it's just kind of an emotional task i
get it
every time stacey and i've moved we've
moved three times and every time we move
she cries
uh it's like a nest and i get it that's
that's a that's a real thing
i don't discount that but the reality is
is that
renting this thing is really not it's
gonna almost be a wash when you talk
about repairs and everything ao i just
i i think it's a relationship question
not a uh
financial question i think you got to
sit down with her and go hey here's the
vision
here's what this does for us we can get
another house we can
but but this is going to change our life
i think you have to sit down and really
walk through it the pros and cons
how long do you plan on uh being with
this uh church joshua
uh it depends i mean we're we're here
for you know as long as the lord has us
here we move to louisville uh from
from alabama in order to to go to
seminary and it's been a
really slow process let me answer this
let me ask you this question
um let's say you move into it
and two years from now let's say you all
do not
are you not at the church do you regret
selling a home two years later i'm
talking about you i never know what your
wife would say
but two years later will you regret
selling a home
probably not no i mean right right now
there are times where it feels like the
i can't think of it plays in but the old
maybe the money pit
um whereas it's just constantly stuff
happening because in order to slip an
older house but it's not bad but it's
it feels like that sometimes great um so
i uh
but no i wouldn't regret it now yeah
okay cool great i agree with
with ken um it sounds like you and your
wife need to get on the same page
and just have a good conversation from a
financial perspective
it makes total sense to sell the home uh
put the rest of it towards the debt uh
because not only did does that
um not only does it put forty thousand
dollars towards the debt but it has
another fourteen thousand dollars
on about another twelve thousand dollars
that can go towards the debt
as well within a year and so you all
will be out of debt
very very quickly um if you all steward
this opportunity the correct way but
i think for me i would rather have peace
than
in my home with my wife than to have
uh be debt-free and i have a little bit
of
drama in my home with my wife so i agree
with ken before y'all make any before
you make any decision
uh make sure that you and your wife are
on the same page and have a real honest
conversation
and speak to her heart uh speak to her
emotional concerns
um and then i think after you do that
hopefully you can win over to your side
and y'all both have
a clear understanding of the big image
i'm not a marriage guy though yeah you
know the only thing i'd add to this uh
joshua is have you sat down and showed
her okay if we sold it
and anthony's right based on what you've
been paying in mortgage
after you've put 40 grand on the debt
you're going to be out of debt pretty
quickly
now all of a sudden you're starting to
save at a higher rate
and have you walked that out with her to
say hey this is what it's going to do to
our monthly budget to where you can
spend more on the kids stuff
we can go on trips we can do things and
even save up for a house that maybe
be better for a growing family have you
walked that entire vision out for her
you know well i guess not uh step by
step and
overall length you know and looking way
out in the future but i mean she's the
one who
we do it together but she handles the
day-to-day money stuff for us and we
work out budgets and stuff like that
together but
uh so she knows the financial picture i
think it's just more of an emotional
attachment
that she has and so i was just trying to
figure out she's not
she's not saying she's not putting her
foot down going we can't do this
correct no no she's giving me the line
if i'll follow you anywhere which of
course
makes me feel bad for drake no no
i like that line yeah i gotta tell you
something i wouldn't feel
bad about that do you believe she means
it
oh oh gosh yeah basically well then dude
come on man
she came here and stayed here with me
some some women say that but they don't
mean it
she means that she's easy yeah listen
you got a good wife
yeah listen um
you got to do this i don't know why i
don't know why you're not doing this
other than the fact that you feel bad i
think you
we just got to the whole point of the
call right there at the end you feel
like you're
making her life worse and i think what
you gotta well you gotta realize she
said she's willing to follow you and you
show her this bigger vision a little bit
more specific
than you have and i think when when you
do that you're gonna feel
like hey i actually am doing the best
thing i am doing the right thing
this is going to pay off down the line
but the fact that she's willing to to
follow you then lead man
come on say that again ken the fact that
she's willing to follow you please man
lead man i mean you know you gotta
put your uh put your big boy pants on
tighten that belt
straighten that back up and go do it man
you are leading your family into a
fantastic financial future
that's what you got to think about
you're not ripping your family out of a
nice home
so that's not what's happening
oh i can't wait to see the comments from
the ladies on this one tomorrow oh this
is gonna be so good
yeah all of a sudden i'm worried about
what i said i have no idea
no fun stuff hey you know look this is a
great great call
this is a great situation and it's
relationship this is a marriage thing
not a money thing but it's gonna have
great money consequences good stuff
there thank you so much joshua
for the call i'm gonna explain marriage
to ao during the break
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions
headquarters i'm ken coleman joined by
anthony o'neal
so thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five
five two two five our scripture of the
day comes from first corinthians 15
58 therefore my dear brothers and
sisters stand
firm let nothing move you always give
yourselves fully to the work of the lord
because you
know that your labor in the lord is not
in vain
our quote today from walter elliott
perseverance is not a long race it is
many short races
one after another triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
let's go to tallahassee florida
where kyle joins us kyle how can we help
hey guys pleasure to speak to you i love
listening to you both thank you so much
how can we help
i got a technical question today about
uh life insurance for my grandmother
um so she's 77 years old and she's on a
fixed
income living on social security she
currently has
a 10k whole life policy
which she pays 30 a month for
the cash value of that is about 3 000
we went and checked on uh chair
insurance and
through xander and they said that the
cheapest they have
would be 254 dollars a month for a
10-year term at 50k
and that's too much for her i was pay
per month at what um
at what payout uh fifty thousand payout
fifty thousand dollars how old is your
grandma that was the lowest
all right she's 77. okay yeah i can
understand that because she is higher up
in age honestly
yeah she has some uh health issues like
scoliosis
but overall she is in good health um so
my question is
should she keep the whole life policy
since it's just 30
a month um or should she take that
three thousand dollars cash value out
and she has another 1500 she could put
with it into
a mutual fund investment all she's
trying to do is cover
uh cremation costs and then anything
above that would just be
gravy that goes to the family does she
have any other savings
uh no not really just that 1500 that she
would be willing to put into the
brokerage account how much is the
cremation cost
uh we're estimating about 10 000 for the
cremation and funeral services
yeah so really if i'm understanding this
the only reason she's even thinking
about the
term life policy is to cover her funeral
costs
yes which the whole life would cover as
well for a lot less per month
yeah ao what you think on that one you
know it's a tough one man
uh because she is higher up in age
um and and xander is right because she
is higher up in age with medical issues
um it is a little it is a little uh
difficult to get the quality insurance
um at this point because she's so far in
i would honestly sit down um uh and
look at the math okay now if she can get
that money raised within the next two
two to three years um then i would
definitely say go ahead and cancel the
whole life and go ahead and just start
stacking the savings
if there is no way possible that she can
get that thing there
then uh because of where she's at i mean
the whole life this insurance policy
because she is in it
may be an okay route i'm not a fan of
whole life insurance i don't i don't
endorse it
but because she is in the latter part we
need to figure out
how do we get this that the bare minimum
taken care of
um and my prayer for my family would be
oh sorry about that go ahead go ahead
i did the math and it'd be about a a six
year break even
for her to get 10k in her brokerage
account with the money that she
would put in there does she have any
kids that i can help her i mean clearly
because i mean but i mean are any of her
kids and anyone alive
that can help her get to that 10k
yeah absolutely um and they're all doing
fine on their own they could
cover the funeral costs but she just
wants to not put any burden on her
family uh for when
she passes yeah i understand i
understand my
my my gut is
um i would honestly cancel the policy
because she's
wasting the money cash it out and invest
it sit down with one of our smartvestor
pros
and let's figure out how to best invest
that money yeah um
and and i think that that you know at
her age i mean
you're expecting her life expectancy i'm
guessing to to to go a bit i guess she's
pretty healthy
yeah she's pretty healthy overall i
would assume she'd make it more than six
years
oh yeah i i think that's what i would do
absolutely um
but yeah contact one of our smartvestor
pros in your area in the tallahassee
area
and uh let's let's cash that out and
let's put that to good use
because it's not gonna help her it's not
gonna gain anything and it's
it's i understand that the cost is so
low but that's part of the marketing
pitch for whole life oh it's only 30
a month well it's just complete waste of
money and
and so yeah i would cash out that and
let's invest that wisely and i think
that's gonna that's gonna
that's gonna be the best move there
triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to phoenix arizona where tina joins us
tina how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call guys you
bet what's up um
i have kind of two problems um today is
my last for sure paycheck that i've
received
and also i'm a public school teacher
and um this year with toba being
interesting
it was kind of crazy but um i'm not
getting a recommendation from my bosses
to go to another school so i'm kind of
like
panicking a little bit because i'm not
quite sure what to do
next why are you not getting a
recommendation from your current bosses
it's personal um i got copied and
like there was a cluster at my school so
so there's been a personality conflict
yes
okay but you uh but has anything been
negative
in your file has there been anything
written up that would go into your
you know your uh uh employment profile
for other schools
um no but it was not we talked a little
bit about that today
and some of that didn't go in because i
said i was going to resign at the end of
the year so i'm just
another school has asked for a
recommendation and she had said no
and now i'm like i don't know how to
move forward because
my points were valid but you can't
change how somebody feels about you
and i really feel like i'm called to be
a teacher
good did you reach out to that yeah i
don't want you to feel like just because
you can't get a recommendation you can't
get a job let's just go ahead and dispel
that myth
okay okay is it gonna be difficult
might be i don't know but it's scarier
than it actually is is what i want you
to hear do you understand what i'm
saying okay
all right so did you reach out to the
school
uh in in the form of applying that then
reached out to your current boss
yes and so have you had any contact with
them
yes and what are they saying are they
moving on from you because
they um the assistant principal took it
to the principal because they wanted me
there and now they're like well
a past school saying yes and one the
current school's saying no and so
i've had to kind of explain myself and
how did that conversation go when you
explained yourself
over well but i mean at what point do
you keep like
like trying to like this is me not what
they think of me
i do know what you mean but the great
news is you would have thought that they
told you to go pound sand
uh they wanted you they got a good
recommendation from one school
and and a non-recommendation or you know
not so good from the current school
and you were able to talk to them about
it you said it went well
they're still thinking about it i get it
but hey
fight for it fight for it here's the
other thing
how many current great recommendations
could you get from other teachers or
other people at your current school or
other schools
and that's that's what i said i've
reached out and i said please talk to
people who are in my classroom on a
daily basis
don't tell them to talk to them go get
the recommendations yourself and flood
their email with it
okay take the bull by the horns tina
so we answer my question how many in
phoenix arizona how many education
contacts do you have that would vouch
for you that you're a really good
teacher and tell a different story
than the story you currently have told
about you how many
too many accounts so
i'd be calling all those people getting
written emails from them and forwarding
to the assistant principal going hey
i understand why you're hesitating i get
it i'm telling you it was a personality
conflict it was a rare situation
i can do this here are all the people
that will vouch for me that will give
you a totally different narrative
than what you're hearing now and it will
match up with the good narrative you got
for me come on tina you gonna fight for
it yeah let's stop worrying about it
and start doing something about it this
isn't gonna stain you for the rest of
your life all right tina you know what
to do
all right i want to thank my colleague
anthony o'neal so fun to be with you on
the air my friend
i want to thank our producer james
childs madison browder
sitting in today for kelly daniel thank
you and thanks to
you america you are why we do the show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you